hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive time to see then what is
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soda and the
daily telegraph's chief political
correspondent christopher hope and
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so as ever let's start
with the front pages the eye splashing
with the prime minister's ambition that
everyone eligible for a coveted booster
vaccine should receive one by the end of
january that's also the lead for the
times
and the metro has word that the army are
being drafted in to help give jabs to
fend off the omicron variant
the delhi telegraph understands that
restrictions put into place by the
government today will last until march
next year they will be reviewed though
every three weeks
bros johnson has contradicted his
leading scientists by telling people
they can party at christmas reports the
guardian
the daily mail also with that pm don't
cancel your christmas
the financial times has the latest on
the us federal reserve's asset purchase
program
and the sun leading with a story about a
car crash reported to involve the
actress sheridan smith
so let's uh go straight to sonia soda
and christopher hope uh christopher to
you first of all on the daily telegraph
front page um new covert restrictions to
last until march next year um you know
forgetting to mention instantly i
suppose the review every three weeks but
what was the mood in the comments today
as they voted this through
well it's like deja vu all over again
when you've got concern amongst uh tory
mps there's not a lot of trust there
about when these uh these powers are
required until the small print lucy
fisher reports in tomorrow's telegraph
says they can keep going until march i
mean that's six months i know of some
tory mps who refused to go for drinks
tonight with boris johnson in
you know as a protest over these powers
this is the row about the pandemic i
mean crumbs we're back to where we were
about a year ago a row between mainly
the tory right the kind of the freedom
lovers on the right wing of the tour
party against scientists with boss
johnson in the middle i mean nothing has
changed really sadly and and kobe keeps
sweeping across the country the
difference of course for these people
concerned about the so-called pandemic
is that there's a lot fewer um people
being put it put it into hospital and
that's that's a blessing i suppose from
omicron so far yeah i mean this once
again causes divisions does it not if we
take a look at the the guardian sonia i
mean for many people having to have a
pcr test when you come back from travel
face masks in certain settings doesn't
go nearly far enough given the number of
cases we have um and it it does for some
though feel like it's the tip of the
iceberg as we roll into christmas and
through winter
which brings us to this clash between
jenny harry's and downing street over
this idea of limiting or socializing
presumably so you can see your old folks
at christmas um what did you make of it
all
well i i do wonder if too much is being
made of a supposed difference between
boris johnson and jenny harry's it's
true that they gave off different
signals so jenny harry's in the press
conference
did say i think it's sort of common
sense really i mean there's no
restrictions on there's no formal
restrictions on socializing but she did
say you know it may be sensible not to
do as much you know to think about what
sort of socializing is necessary she
didn't tell us not to go out and
socialize it's not inconsistent with
doing things in the run-up to christmas
and indeed some scientists are saying
it's just about being sensible and
there's no requirement on people to do
it but to be honest i think quite often
the public in fact
at every stage of this pandemic the
public have been ahead of the government
on this so the public has often started
to take action before the government has
mandated it and and you know i've heard
of lots of instances of um you know
companies perhaps thinking about um
christmas parties etc um maybe people
thinking well i've got four christmas
parties coming up in the next couple of
weeks i could miss these two but i'm
going to go to these two because i'm
seeing my elderly parents and i want to
minimize the risk i mean at this point
in time it's really up to individual
choice and i sort of think what jenny
harry said was common sense and and
people
they want to but um they don't have to
um so you know i i do think that perhaps
there's been um
it is clear that boris johnson doesn't
want to give out that signal and um and
you know they say there's definitely a
perceived contradiction there when he
was sort of he's he was saying today uh
there's no reason to cancel anything but
i sort of think you you can sort of you
know there's an element of consistency
you don't have to cancel it but also be
sensible and think about what you really
need and want to do particularly if
you're seeing older relatives yeah you i
can see you've got christmas lights up
unless they're the all year round type
it felt christmasy outside downey street
today as well
what did you say i probably did i talked
to all of you
i was just saying i i was one of those
people who put their christmas tree up
really early i did it a whole week ago i
thought we need a bit of like
well i mean i was going to say
christopher um feeling pretty
christmassy at downing street too
was this the event you were talking
about for those who protested and did
not turn up or was this something
different um we know boris johnson takes
christmas really seriously he did last
year he kept trying to keep hold of this
idea of a family celebration so why slap
down as many you know people reported
today or contradict jenny harris who to
some made a perfectly sensible
suggestion that just keep just keep an
eye on what you're doing this is this is
a crowd disease after all
it's the old debate isn't it about um
politicians trying to push for
greater individual freedom a bit like
what sonia was arguing for there i
thought against what scientists are
arguing and there's a feeling that
there's a degree of wanting of certainly
through the past 80 months in crumbs are
we a bit tired of this argument of
scientists and medical experts trying to
clamp down on individual freedoms i
think sonia's right you know i think you
should be down for what what you feel
comfortable with if you feel you can't
go to four parties just go to two and
look after yourself and be be careful if
you're seeing an elderly relative all
that makes sense i think that's where
the politics should be and the problem
is with this big we know we've talked
about uh doves and hawks in the cabinet
who's in favor of lockdown who isn't um
you know it's so tedious i really hope
that i think um as sonia says i hope we
have all moved on a bit we've learned a
lot more about kobe about ourselves as a
nation and we can be trusted more to get
it right and that means taking care
wearing a mask because a mask means that
you know you're being uh you're thinking
of somebody else that's how we should be
at christmas
uh and in the meantime of course more
details of how they're gonna get this
enormous booster jab program out to
everybody uh the eye is going for this
and they've set a deadline as well this
ambition of giving every adult their
booster by at the end of january so once
again setting great stall by the vaccine
program sonia
that's right and i think everyone would
agree that vaccines are the first line
of defense against omnicron this new
variant i think it's really important to
say we don't know how serious omnicron
is yet it might turn out to be okay and
not that much worse than delta it may
turn out to be more variant and more
infectious and one of the reasons why
the government's put in these measures
is because it wants to take time over
the next three weeks to figure out
exactly what we're looking at but
vaccines are the first line of defense
they may not be the only line of defense
that we need in the end but they are
absolutely the first line of defense and
so that's why the government i think
quite rightly has put a lot of emphasis
on ramping up the booster program over
the next two months it was a little bit
of you know i wasn't 100 clear because
boris johnson's referenced everyone
having the chance to have a booster by
the end of january um uh an official
said that everyone would have the chance
to book a booster by the end of january
two are slightly different but um the
sentiment is very much there uh the
papers are reporting
tomorrow that that means stepping up
from two and a half million vaccines a
week to three and a half million
vaccines so that's a huge thing that the
nhs and community pharmacies have to
deliver just at the time when the nhs is
in a real winter crunch really
struggling um for capacity there's huge
staff shortages across the surface so it
is going to be a really big challenge in
the nhs but everything that i've heard
uh from organizations like the nhs
confederation you know it sounds like
the nhs with the help of the army it can
be pulling out all the stops to to make
booster jabs happen yeah
yeah once again uh being involved uh 400
i mean it's not it's not huge numbers to
be fair but um we know they're great at
logistics will that make a difference
well it might do when the army would
were dragged out from the barracks to
drive um uh lorries in the in the great
petrol shortage that happened in you
know around the early uh late september
early october they're becoming this this
kind of
um
reserve force which steps in at any
point so i wonder whether they use a bit
of cover by politicians to show they are
properly getting their grips with it i
mean the army's been called in how bad
can it be so i was a degree of that i
think but i mean you know why not it's a
big it's a big push to make christmas
happen so why not yeah and in terms of
the throwing everything at it booster
program sonia um you know some some
people say might say why were we so
hesitant in the first place i mean older
people will have died because they
didn't get their booster early enough uh
in the autumn the evidence from israel
was already there we had a we had a slow
start to that and indeed to the
vaccination of children too
yeah i think it's really interesting i
was listening to an interview with a
member of jcbi um yesterday and they
said you know the benefit hindsight is a
fine thing and with the benefit of
hindsight you know they personally
wished um or personally thought it would
have been better to get the booster
program um running more quickly
but things changed so quickly in the
pandemic and i suppose and what what he
was saying was that back in the summer
when they were taking all these
decisions we didn't have very high
infection rates
um you know
we didn't even really have a delta
significantly on the scene yet so a lot
has changed and i guess it just shows
how much you sort of need to plan for
the worst in this pandemic but yeah i
think with hindsight lots of people
would say well it would have been better
to get it off more quickly and i think
it's really interesting because jcbi the
independent committee that advised the
government make recommendations on on
sort of immunization programmes uh they
they were really really they really got
it right on the gap between first and
second doses and they attracted all
sorts of criticism from all sorts of
quarters and they've been proved right
on that but their decisions on children
have been very slow and they've come in
for a lot of criticism
in that so i think you know it it it is
it's interesting that that they did sort
of seem to take quite a slow decision on
on on extending to children
and christopher just one thought about
the the conservative position on this um
returning to where we started the daily
daily telegraph quoting the same old
voices to be fair craig mckinley
who said regulations could deter people
from going to a christmas party or the
pub for fear of getting pinged before
christmas day and having to miss out on
seeing family and friends steve baker
criticizing ministers for taking away
the public's right to choose what they
do based on evidence that he claimed was
flimsy and uncertain um you know what
what is the uh
the politics behind that view
and
are they a loud voice in the ear of
downing street
well this is it's a small cohort of
around three dozen tory mps they're
battle hardened and they fought these
fights a year ago didn't they um and
they just did
not a lot of trust i think
with number 10 um and and the and these
these many right-wing tory mps and
that's the problem it's not going to
mean that we have any any any rebellions
because the other parties are brought in
favor of these restrictions but it just
shows a degree of of disaffection
with with number 10 and don't forget
we're looking into a big by-election on
thursday in old bexie and sid cup and
then one two weeks hence in north
shropshire which i know the tories are
more worried about with a strong lib dem
showing there so you know the politics
never ends but i think you know i think
look even look at the headline there in
the eye which is hardly friendly to
boris johnson he'll be pretty pleased
tonight that that kind of works you know
that works and he looks like he's taking
action being decisive and number 10
during a pandemic there's little more
you can be
okay
i'll go on yep shoot go for it yeah you
can say one thing that i would comment
on on the pandemic as i think it's
really easy to blow those concerns out
of proportion actually because it's
important to remember we've only got 22
confirmed cases of omicron at the moment
and you only have to self-isolate if you
come into contact with someone with
omicron not other variants of covid
which you know delta is a is a dominant
and i suspect that in you know in three
weeks we were like we will know why
actually a if micron is a lot worse and
it's becoming dominant in which case i
think we could see those self-isolation
guidelines expanded
or or actually if we don't need to worry
about it in which case i think we'll see
them back so i don't think this is going
to lead to a specific omicron specific
uh pandemic let's put it like that
i mean i mean for three weeks it's
december the 20th sonia so
it's going to be tricky to focus on on
it all then and sonia daily telegraph on
its front page as well as the covert
restrictions once again reflects on some
of the knock-on impact of this uh with
these startling and and and you know
scary figures about possible cancer
cases that have been missed
that's right so up to 740 000 um uh
740
yeah a thousand sorry
uh cases according to the telegraph
there and i think this refers to two
things that have really emerged in
recent months so first is misdiagnosis
which is what this article is about so
people who may not necessarily have got
the referrals they need or maybe even
just stayed away from the gp when they
had um
worrying symptoms and so cases that were
actually missed and then secondly we
know that waiting lists for treatment
have have grown hugely in record levels
and um i mean i just think it's it's
really dreadful for people um and the
nhs was so over has been so overburdened
with the pandemic that it hasn't
possibly been able to treat people um
suffering from covert very acutely and
keep up with everything else
that it would normally be doing and you
know even going into this pandemic the
nhs was really really um very very low
on excess capacity thanks to an
incredibly tight funding settlement over
over the last 10 years so i do think
this is really troubling and i think
it's a reminder actually going forward
you know we we are suffering very sadly
still quite high death rates numbers of
deaths from covered although a lot lower
than we were at the pandemic peak but
it's not even just about minimizing the
number of deaths in this you know when
we take measures it's about protecting
the nhs from getting dangerously
overburdened
and and so that that will be a big if we
see restrictions come in as a result of
omicron protecting the nhs and ensuring
that people can for example still get
cancer treatment will be a big part of
why
go for it
well i was yeah
yes to all that but i think this plays
into this debate about why you can't see
your own gp
and my mum told me that the only gp she
can see um is on the tv when there's
some drama i mean she can't get to see
any gps anymore and you can't see one i
mean and that's the point when you see a
gp possibly they may pick and may pick
up on issues of issues of early stage
cancer
doctor in this article here dr gary
halson the vice chairman of the royal
college of gps he makes sure that gpu
take their responsibility very seriously
and worked hard throughout the pandemic
and of course we must always protect the
nhs but equally there's a balance here i
think a lot of people know or i know
someone certainly whose mother died and
because she couldn't push her her cancer
was not picked up soon enough and i
think there's lots of cases like that
out there and that's what national law
of support is showing yeah but that's a
danger of having cases run so hot i mean
covered cases allowing them to be in
their tens of thousands every day that's
the knock-on impact you've got to keep
doctors safe isn't it you've got 20
seconds on the last story which is
anti-migrant rage at lifeboat heroes
this is the metro and other papers in
fact as well sonia
well this is just a dreadful story so r
and lie we're about to send out a
lifeboat to do a rescue at sea of um
people seeking refuge
made the very dangerous crossing across
the channel and some people physically
tried to stop them by sort of standing
in front of the boat as it launched so
um i just think really dreadfully sad
story